first of all it is so good to see you
guys how is it to see each other like we
saw each other about a year was it a
year ago or two years ago now that we
saw each other in training you I feel
like a year yeah I think it was a year
ago when we were all be together I'm it
for sure yeah so have you guys like are
you still close because that's the thing
that we all sort of wish for after being
huge fans of the show that like we we
all came in terms of the fact that the
show was ending but we would not be able
to come to terms at the fact that you
guys did not maintain the relationship
after the show ended well you know it's
so funny is that kind of like Amanda I
ended up moving out west and so it's
your whole life imitated art we at Laura
and I actually kind of have been in and
out of touch over that period of time so
even if we're not closed
it's funny how we've been able to kind
of reconnect and it's like time doesn't
really pass you can see that it does but
it doesn't feel like it it's very
comfortable to be with Loni and to be
able to just chat about whatever and
it's passed even though we physically
are distanced yeah so how you feel -
honey 1000% and here on social media
your like social media girl so we're
there - so for sure is timeless you know
like yeah you connect with Laura and
it's like I just saw her yesterday so
it's beautiful during especially during
now during this time when we're all at
home and people are worried and things
just aren't right we're sort of looking
for things that make us feel comfortable
and sort of you know nostalgia is really
big right now and just even sitting down
thinking about ready or not you know it
gives you that sense of home it gives
you that sort of sense of comfort are
you guys feeling that now
feeling the ready or not comforter you
know you know like yeah like are you
guys looking for those sorts of things
because we look to things like you know
like your show and I'm just wondering if
you guys are sort of like finding
comfort in things you know maybe not not
necessarily your own show but but but
but but you know but things that you you
sort of like you grew up with oh for
sure like you can just hang out to
people that you have to in a long time I
think it's funny I found myself doing
that almost instantly making sure that
you had like a little touchstone so that
for sure was one of my first things that
I did but you like yeah that's
definitely like I've been connecting
with people I haven't talked to in a
while and having like phone
conversations and video conversations
which is kind of stuff that we didn't do
before which I realized that that human
connection is something that is
definitely rising and it's a beautiful
thing you know sort of uncomfortable
crazy time yeah you got you guys were
part of whether it was ready or not or
Degrassi Canada really led the way in
sort of no-holds-barred teen youth
programming that actually served a great
purpose yeah yeah both of those shows
did a lot mostly because it looked at
teen issues without laughing at it so
even though there might have been a bit
of humor or a bit of you know levity
that would be surrounding it it wasn't
actually making fun or poking fun of
these feelings emotions or experiences
that we were having and I think it lent
a lot of authenticity to the viewers so
much so that we actually received
letters from families not just teens
that were viewing it but parents who
said this is the first time I've ever
had a platform to talk about this with
my child and thank you and I remember
thinking like that's that's a big deal
because it wasn't making fun of those
things which can actually be very
impactful to a young girl to a family
agreed it's almost as if because you
guys were blazing such a trail with what
you talked about and how you handled
those things you would think that now in
2020 that everything would just be wide
open and we would have gone way past
what you guys did but it hasn't happened
yeah you would think there's strides and
there's openings in there's
conversations happening but it's
definitely not as wide open as you think
in this day and age which is really
interesting to me still you know
everybody has their time with things and
at least to have a conversation
open up you know that's a positive
that's a silver lining that certain
things wouldn't have even been talked
about before so the show was all over
the world when did you realize how big
the show was do you remember the moment
where you were like whoa between the two
of us not necessarily but like I had
personal experiences where indication in
Mexico and yeah all of a sudden one of
the women came and gave me a drum that
the guy was making drums in the lobby
and I'm like oh cool like things and
then they were like oh we know who you
are like you're a big deal you're famous
like you're from ready or not and then
you know I got VIP at the buffet it was
a big deal and you know when you're just
living life I don't think you realize
until you have those kind of experiences
you know where people are like we love
you and you're a huge deal and you're
like oh right are you like like why I
said it wasn't really something that we
were cognizant of so much of as it was
going on we knew that people had seen
the show but it kind of felt like a
small family local type of thing I was
backpacking in the Mexican highlands
actually you like just outside of
Chiapas and I was in this tiny town I
had to take a chicken bus like six hours
to get to this town and this
kind of abduct amigos Amanda I'm like I
was like this is not a place I would
have fixed it like you couldn't see I
don't know I you couldn't see
advertising anywhere and then all of a
sudden this guy walks up to me I was
like wow that was mind-blowing
we all know and I'm wondering over the
years since it happened how many times
have you answered questions about what
it was like that day Ryan Gosling was on
the show like that's a big topic of
conversation it's funny because um I it
was like we didn't really know obviously
at the time people were gonna be like
explosive stars he was super cute and
super nice and good local boy and then
so was Dominic Sam pronia who was the
other actor who was playing with him at
the time and really great guys but then
of course when you see someone explode
like that you're like oh my gosh and
then you're like wait a second
holy cow I didn't even really remember
until I decided to just look at a thread
of a conversation about ready or not and
everybody was tripping out that it was
Ryan Gosling and I was like what show
like why I remember like he had longer
hair he was not super confident and I
was like whoa that's so cool that was
totally Ryan Gosling so in 2020
everything is being rebooted if they
came to you and said we want to do a
sort of next generation and move ready
or not forward would you guys be into it
yeah yeah oh yeah oh yeah where do you
where do you think they would be where
do you think that those two would be
right now oh well it's kind of something
that's being developed right now if I
mean that
[Music]
but we would be on paths that would be
very divergent that would come back and
much the same way that we did seen them
part as young women you see them as
mature women coming back so hold on here
are you guys doing ready or not again
and I'm just finding this out now well I
believe it's in development so we don't
obviously have anything concrete at the
moment that we've been told from our
creator that we are at liberty to say
that it's being worked on I was about to
wrap up but now I need to know where
does this where does this pick up like
what are your lives like know yet we
have ideas listen I cannot thank you
guys enough for filling me in on that as
we say goodbye I'm going to email Ryan
Gosling to let him thank you guys enough
and I'm so happy I know a lot of people
are with that news so thank you so much
it was wonderful to talk to you and I
cannot wait to do this again Thank You
Roz for having it - so great talking to
you